ومن ثم تواجه ربما الولايات الموجوده في
القريبه من هذه الولايات الجنوبيه يمكن
ايضا ان تساعد في ارسال
مساعدات لكن حتى الان لا نعلم حقيقه حاله
الطرق حتى يتم ارسال المساعدات كما ذكرت
في نادي وكما تحدثنا في النشرات السابقه
الحديث عن تحديات للسفر من السفر خلال
الايام الماضي نتيجه العاصفه الثلجيه
دلاله على قوه هذه العاصفه تم تعطيل
المدارس اليوم مسبقا كانت المدارس في عطله
عديد من المدن منها انقره واسطنبول وغازي
عنتاب نتيجه العاصفه الثلجيه وجاء اليوم
الزلزال ليزيد بيكون هذه الكارثه والظروف
الجويه هي ما تزيد هذه الامور تعقيدا اعيد
فقط هنا معلومه جديده وصلت من افاق قبل
قليل بلغ عدد الهزات الارتجابيه حوالي 66
هزه ارتداديه بعد الزلزال وما زاد افادت
تؤكد على الاحصائيه القديمه 76 شخصا و440
76 شخصا نقوا مصائهم 440 جريحا